[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌사남입니다 제가
오늘은
경매 낙찰된 사례를 가지고 얘기해
보려고 하는데 최근에 두 건 그
도산대로에서 낙찰된 사례가 있어요
그래서
청담동의 한 건이랑 신사동의 한 건이
두 건을 가지고 좀 영상을 찍어
보도록 하겠습니다
우선 두 건 다 공유물 분할 때문에
이제 경매가 나왔던 그런 사례고요
그리고 재밌는 거는 두 건물 다 같은
소유 줍니다
작년에도 또 하셨더라구요
작년에도 삼성동에 건물이 있었는데
그것도 공유물 분할로 인해서 이제
경매를 진행했었고 그 낙찰자리까지
같이 좀 설명을 드리겠습니다
첫 번째로 청담동에 이제 낙찰된
사례인데
2023년 1월 31일 날 이제
진행했던 그 경매 사례고요 감정가
금액이
976억원 최저 입찰 금액으로 시작을
했는데
낙찰가는 무려 1517억에
낙찰이 됐습니다 그래서 최자 최저
입찰 금액의 한 155% 일단
낙찰자가 한 명 있었어요 최저가로
썼어도 낙찰될 수 있었는데 이렇게 좀
155%의 이런 낙찰 금액이 낙찰이
됐었고요 위치는 여기 청담사거리
앞에 있는 건물인데 여기가 이제
코너에 접하고 있고
지은지가 그렇게 오랜 되진 않았어요
그래서 되게 깔끔한 10년 정도
됐어요 그리고이 건물이 이제 용적률
거의 800% 받았거든요 그때 당시에
노선 상업지
기준으로 이제 800% 허가를 내주는
그런 시기가 있었는데 그거에 적용을
받아서 이제 800%
허가를 받은 그런 건물이라고 보시면
될 것 같습니다 그 도산대로 변해서
이렇게 좀
깔끔하고
뭔가 용적률을 다 받은 건물이
그렇게 많진 않거든요
다른 건물보다는 좀 메리트 있는
가격에
낙찰이 된 거 같습니다
작년 말에 또 매각당 사례가 있는데
작년 말에 여기 세신빌딩이라고
요게 이제 또 낙찰이 됐었어요 연면적
땅 한 4천 초반 정도의 매각된
사례고 요게 돼 311평 정도 됐고
그래서 평단가로 봤을 때는
5억 3천 정도
연면적은 4,100평입니다 무려
그래서 연면적당 한 4100만원
정도에 매각된 사례고
용적률이 이거는 959%예요
용적률이 굉장히 좀 높은 건물이었고
1667억에
작년 12월에 매각이 됐습니다 그리고
여기 뒤에 저희가 잘 아는 그 새벽집
부지도 같이 매입을 했어요 지금
10번지랑 11번지 같이 매입을
했습니다 그래서 10번지만 가격 봤을
때는 한 2억 중반 그래서
뭔가이 두 개를 합쳐서 지진 않을 것
같아요 제 개인적인 생각은
앞에 건물이
워낙 용적률을 좀 많이 받았기 때문에
좀이 건물만 유지하고
새벽집만 좀 신축하지 않을까 이렇게
생각이 듭니다
요거는 한 4천만원
초반
정도 매각이 되는데 이번에 이제 그
낙찰이 된 거는 거의 5천만원
정도의
매각이 됐어요 보면은 돼지가
283평이고
연면적이 2,695평
지하 2층에 지상 15층 건물이고
용적률 거의 800% 다 받았고
그래서 1517억
감안했을 때
땅 가격은 5억 3천만원 그리고
연면적당은
5,500만원에
매각이 됐습니다 세신빌딩보다는
금액이 좀 높은 그런 수준이라고 좀
보시면 될 것 같아요 그리고 또
최근에 신사동에
똑같은 이름의 똑같은 소유주의 빌딩이
또 경매에 나왔었습니다 그리고 요거는
돼지가 좀 컸습니다 그래서
456평이고
연면적이
2242평이에요 그리고 최저가가
1,178억원에 나왔었는데
낙찰된 거는
1,253억 해가지고 106%에
낙찰이 됐습니다 저는 개인적으로
개인적인 생각입니다 전 개인적으로
이거 너무 잘 샀어요 이건
이 건물 정말
정말 싸게 잘 샀습니다이 용적률이
그렇게 높진 않은 건물이었는데 이것도
노선 상업지에요 그래서
땅 가격으로 봤을 땐 한 2억 7천
정도
도산대로가 지금 신축부지 같은
경우에는 보통 한 3억에서 4억 정도
예상을 하는데 그 시세보다는 좀
저렴하게
매입을 했고
연면적당 가격으로 봤을 때는
5,500만원인데 이게 사실 용적률이
좀 많지는 않아서 지금 한 280%
정도 받았거든요 지금 요겁니다
땅이 땅이 너무 크고 좋아요 지금
가중평균 해봤을 때도 280% 보다는
더 받을 것 같아요 제 예측은 한
400% 때까진 받을 것 같거든요
건물을 더 올릴 수도 있는 거죠
위치도 너무 좋아요 이제 도산공원
사거리에 위치하고 있고 그리고 저는요
건물을 되게 잘 산 거 같아요 제가
좋아하는 건물입니다 이것만 지워도
용적률은 좀 더 올릴 그런 여지도 좀
있고요 그래서 시세보다 되게 좀
저렴하게 잘
매입한 그런 건물이라고 보시면 될 것
같아요고 작년에도
낙찰된 사례인데 똑같은 소유죠 또
똑같은 소유죠
똑같은 소유진데 아 이것도 이제
작년에 한창 그
경매 시장에서 좀 이슈가 됐던 그런
건물입니다 그래서 삼성동에 있는 그
대로변에 있는 건물이었고 대지가
355평
면면적이
913평이었습니다
처음에 최저 매각가액은 한
436억이었는데
낙찰은 무려
620억에 낙찰이 됐습니다 그래서
141% 이제 낙찰이 됐고
입찰은 총 16명이었어요 그때
당시에는 워낙 또 장이 좋았고 그래서
굉장히 좀
그래도 관심이 많았고 많은 분들이 좀
들어왔었던 것 같아요 620억
이게 355
하면은 한 1억 7천 정도
매입한 것으로 보여지고 근데 이거는
앞서 그 두 건과 다르게 여기에 있는
3종이에요요 대로변에 있거든요
삼성로 뭐 지금이 건물 상태에서
건물을 더 뭐 높게 올리거나
그러긴
쉽지 않습니다 지금 상태가 어떻게
되면 최적의 상태입니다
물론 이제 리모델링해서 가치를 올릴
수 있지만 여기서 저는이 낙찰된
사례를 보면서 느낀 점이 일단은 주요
지역에 있는 거는
그래도 뭐 100% 이상 다
낙찰이 됐었고 그리고 심지어 청담동은
155% 최저가 대비해서 그 정도로
낙찰이 됐었고 그 두 번째로는 일단
이분이 건물을 참 많이 가지고
계셨구나네 그리고 공유물
분할을 위한 경매가 생각보다 그런
분쟁들이 또 많구나 또 이런 생각도
좀 하게 됐고 아 그래도 돈 있는
사람들은
그래도 계속
투자를 하는구나라고 좀 많이
했었고 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다